[Music]
happy Friday welcome back to certified
country we are here bringing you another
very special Christmas edition of the
show with my buddy Dustin Lynch hello
hello thank you for being here
great to be here how are you getting
ready for the holidays are you ready I'm
ready yes I'm prepared what are you
asking for
we're sleep that's number one and
actually I've got myself some bathing
suits because I've got some beach time
coming up yeah yeah my schedule I hate
the cold okay I've gotten really good at
dodging that in January and February and
this year I'm gonna go on some trips
overseas and those trips involved
beaches nice yes where are you going I'm
gonna go to Vietnam amazing I go to
Thailand and then I come from there and
I go to my fourth year in a row with
Luke Bryan down it crashed my apartment
yes well the sleep and the fun I would
say is hard-earned you just wrapped your
tour Congrats coming up in 2018 I'm
working on a new little project and we
put out we put out a teaser we put out a
little version of it's called the
strippers in a small town boy mhm and
that kind of inspired like that was fun
I want to do some more of this so I've
got to get in this video over the next
couple of months and get that finished
up I don't know what's gonna come of it
yet I'm just gonna kind of go in with a
plain page are you saying more
stripped-down versions more
stripped-down yeah we'll just see where
it goes I'm gonna I'm gonna try and
write some new stuff for it to just have
some fun I'd go back out with Brad
Paisley in the January believe it or not
yeah back out back out with him so
that's gonna be awesome
and he's a good time here yeah all right
well to get in the holiday spirit a
little bit I want to play some Christmas
mad libs okay alright so I need you to
give me an adjective any any ski me me
me this is gonna be good already I can
tell
part of body like what do you mean part
help I'm a pre-med student so I could
get over here here don't like like she
was like a first grade level like nerds
tummy okay though innards don't give me
like a spleen verb um
shimmy shimmy shimmy yeah I like her
than a dancer are you yeah show me a
little shimmy and another plural now
candy cane and he came all right I'm
gonna let you read my sloppy handwriting
okay I read your story Santa Claus is a
steamy man who wears a beautiful blue
suit with a sweet belt and a burning red
hat hey we're not bad I know you got it
he's like an American yeah red one blue
guy he has a long slimy green beard okay
now it's getting bad and his tummy
shakes like jelly when he laughs that
one was spot-on
nailed it mm-hmm every Christmas he
rides a girl full of presents pulled my
493 Jaguars high into the night sky
Santa shimmies down the chimney of
people's homes to leave reindeers polar
bears and candy canes under their
Christmas trees that was that was the
slimy green beard he's got a little hand
of grand sitting beneath a Yoda mean one
mr. couch
I'm trying to figure out he's riding a
girl yeah that's when I knew it was
taking a turn oh they all need see
everybody all right so we are gonna play
some Christmas Carol pictionary here I
have my Santa hat with Christmas Carol
titles in here this is gonna be a mess
I can't suck at drawing all right three
two go all right let's see and I can't
talk right it
oh my god I said is somebody with a lot
of hair a girl Mary Mary a mary did you
know
oh great start
oh my god okay this is a lot I mean I
was almost I didn't even get to baby G
what else Oh baby Jesus is that sue that
was gonna be yes sweet baby Jesus okay
okay I don't know how I'm gonna do this
one all right you sit over here
okay we said no words but we didn't say
no numbers one that isn't one it is a
one told us a Christmas um no this is
Carol what they thought with a blurred
one in it a variation of one oh my god I
think we're cheating I don't think we're
supposed to talk with no way you're
gonna guess this pass all right
it was Noel oh man how the heck do you
illustrate that okay this one I can do
you should have done like a trophy and a
chain like a checkered flag I might have
gotten first all right Dustin I don't
need to learn in my life what is it
angel yes okay
in the ER mm-hmm do I know this
something about here hi know what I'm
trying to draw it out you've got it too
hazel is that right yep angel heard
I don't know Christmas carols really
enjoy one more word angel heard this is
a word hi
yes angel angel heard huh what angels we
have heard on high
I don't know that one flat okay our
mom's going do you need some Church in
your life my gosh I don't know this one
either I can draw it though the bowel
okay very good bowel not gonna get the
rest of this no oh so we got that was
kind of a two people three people
the three wise men
no okay singing yes yes yes you've got
people singing uh-huh you said it all
carol carol of the bells there we go
yeah let's go see you know your curls
but I don't know that one
you don't know what no all right well
hopefully you know what Carolyn game
stinks this one you have to know if you
do not know this if I don't know this
and you're never gonna invite me back
I'm gonna retrace your little people
okay better sing okay follow my love I'm
officially the worst play this no
singing what is that SOT silent night
yeah oh my gosh oh I know this one okay
okay this is one of my favorite ears
heard okay very good very good very good
your brain of gears are very different
than mine so yeah what two people
hearing uh-huh did you hear Oh what is
that song ha ha ha do you hear what I
hear
oh my gosh that's my ear sir
your ears are questionable happy smiling
mm-hmm
drawing just point out the cop that she
drew so this is North America perfect
okay fine to the world yeah let's go
what's on top of the world here
the nightfall okay I didn't realize it
look like that whoo
here you go we're gonna get this girl we
are yep all right I'm ready let's see
let's see little drummer boy let's go
yeah now that's man that was really good
that was great Wow I didn't have to put
a North Pole on it thank you so much for
being here that was so much fun thank
you guys so much for watching if this is
your first time with us please subscribe
to Entertainment Tonight on YouTube we
are bringing you new episodes each and
every Friday
however we are gonna take a little bit
of a hiatus to enjoy the holidays so we
will be back in 2018 with brand new
episodes in the meantime though be sure
to follow Dustin on social media what's
the handle Dustin Lynch music bye guys